help you my bathrobe this bathrobe
belongs to a young woman named Liza who
my roommate Josh used to date things are
weird now that he knows that I'm 40
women lie about their age all the time
it's not a new concept we're gonna be 26
year old bosses I can't start over in
this business as a 40 year host liza
liza get in here and shut the door he
never thought that I would be her at
this age I definitely never thought I'd
be here at this age the show critics
loved and filmed the door is back with a
brand new season thank you for keeping
my secret obviously words are worth
keeping and the stakes are even higher I
wish I could ask you to come in if I
could get both of us no problem oh I'm
gonna have to be two people Aiza you
think you can do that I think I can I
don't know what's going on here I did
not know that that was your daughter
I feel such an imposter so do I every
single day I can't be in your life
where's your young man I'm not sure
there still is a young man
it's all gonna get better in her 30s
yeah
younger season - Wednesdays at 10:00
starting January 13th on TV land